okay let's go next to our caller from
the 206 area code who's there from 206
hi that is you yeah who's this hi this
is Leon in Seattle hey Leon Hey first of
all this is pretty cool that I'm
actually on this line I thought about
condom for a little while but I wasn't
sure about timing and I'm a longtime fan
so awesome
thanks for the content yeah I guess I
have a question about the recent tweets
in regards to Israel I'm sure you've
probably got a few of them I'm kind of a
of agreement with your final point in
that wait hold on a second let me back
up just a second are you did I tweet
something about Israel
oh no Oman oh ill on Omar's tweets yeah
okay and I kind of agree with your final
point in in your video about one can
understand that these comments may or
may not play on tropes for a specific
group or identity and still for example
in this specific scenario support
boycotting Israel and so for me it just
kind of begs to a question because I
know that recently took a call from
someone in regards to ALC and
essentially your point was that um it in
regards to criticizing her and and
whether or not Chris criticisms of her
are sexist or racist and and I believe
you brought an analogy towards Sarah
Palin so I guess I just wanted to see
like how you reconcile those two things
because the way I see it is we can we
can retroactively we see that a deist
row these are playing on tropes but it
doesn't necessarily take away from the
validity of the of the actual statement
I have no idea what what you mean I
apologize so you're you want me to
reconcile which two things and witch
tropes do or don't take away from the
validity of which particular argument
yeah and and
there's a question oh yeah and I'm gonna
yeah I just want to say a forehand I
didn't have my my question ready so I do
apologize for that I kind of call it
like very last-minute I got it you had a
video for a call but um essentially it's
uh so as a leftist we can say okay there
is a global there is a there is a trope
about Jewish globalism and Jews control
money got it and that these statements
may or may not marry not can be viewed
as okay this validates my racist
anti-semitic George Soros themed Jews
control everything okay but we can still
be like hey AIPAC is a problem and the
the far-right government in Israel is a
problem right so I don't see how and
again I apologize I don't have my
question ready I didn't like reference
the last video I just remember having
seen it and having thoughts myself like
you know you can you can understand that
people questioning al C's intelligence
plays into tropes about women and
specifically women of color or not in a
very intelligent but you can still
maintain a you know any criticism you
might have of her overstatement okay III
apologize I just don't understand the
question but let me put it this way I am
against the right amount government I
make I'm against the right wing
Netanyahu government in Israel and I
share the concern of those who believe
that the tweets from Alon Omar without
necessarily indicating that she's
personally anti-semitic certainly didn't
help the fact that there is this probe
about Jewish conspiracy to control via
the use of money so that I mean that's
how I reconcile it that that's just my
view it's very loud where you are so I'm
gonna let you go and in that note I'm
gonna go to a break sorry to everybody
who is holding who I didn't get to will
take calls again and I look forward to
hearing from you